ردا على اتهامات موسكو باريس تنفي وجود
مرتزقه لها في اوكرانيا او في اي مكان
اخر لا يوجد مرتزقه فرنسيون في اوكرانيا
ولا في اي مكان اخر على عكس دول اخرى انها
اتهامات باطله وتلاعب من قبل روسيا فلا
يجب ان نعطيها اهميه كبيره كالتها مات
السابقه وحتى الاتهامات التي ستاتي بعد
هذه وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه من جانبها
استدعت السفير الفرنسي بعد تدمير نقطه
تمركز للمقاتلين الاجانب في مقاطعه خاركيف
ومن بينهم فرنسي تم استدعاء السفير
الفرنسي الى وزاره الخارجيه على خلفيه
تدمير القوات الروسيه نقطه تمركز مؤقته
للمقاتلين الاجانب في مقاطعه خاركيف
والقضاء على عدد كبير ومن بينهم عشرات
الفرنسيين موسكو كانت قد اعلنت الاربعاء
انها استهدفت على حد تعبيرها مجموعه من
المقاتلين الفرنسيين في ضربه على مدينه
خاركيف بشرق اوكرانيا ادت بحسب السلطات
المحليه الى اصابه العديد من المدنيين
بجروح وتتعرض مدينه خركي التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا جزئيا للقصف بانتظام وتخشى السلطات
الاوكرانيه من هجوم وشيك على المنطقه حيث
امرت باخلاء اكثر من 20 بلده